let's do a new NFL offseason where
Vaughn chooses who's going to win the
Super Bowl by going to a new team every
summer like and make it like The
Bachelor this it didn't happen like that
I always felt like I was gonna stay with
the Denver Broncos and I was going to be
a Denver Bronco for the rest of my
career you know it was really close to
be like a forever home and I just never
had the thought that I would leave I got
traded to the Los Angeles Rams so when I
got there I also started to feel like
okay this is you know where I want to
end you know it's La got to play with
Aaron Donald like Hall of Fame and I had
Leonard Floyd and Jalen Ramsey and I had
all these guys around me and the lights
and it's Hollywood I never really
thought that I would leave LA and then
free agency came this is a great idea
man I I like uh the best of style I can
tell you this right now I'm not leaving
Buffalo this is a great place I love
this place you know we're gonna do some
some special things here and I want to
be a part of it